the next award is that of cinematography
now when we when we say cinematography
you know after all it's a word that some
of the people when out in our industry
might not understand you see when you
get the xxx film and the super chrome
and you use it well nevermind I think I
have to get someone else out here who
can explain the whole thing miss Joan
Collins the beautiful and talented
John would you be a help to me please
and explain to everyone what a
cinematographer is please well let me
see the cinematographer is a dedicated
artist he's the man who comes on the set
very early in the morning before any of
the actors arrived he checks the lenses
and then he straightens the lights he
gets behind the camera looks at you till
the finder and then straightens up and
says so where were you last night don't
you ever tell them God
the nominees are milton Krasner for an
affair to remember jack Hilliard for the
bridge on the river kwai ray jun for
funny face
william mela for Peyton Place and
Ellsworth Frederick's to sayonara the
winner is the ridge on the river kwai
jack
I accept this award for Jack Hillyard
who is in London at the time he wishes
to thank each and every one that
contributed to this award for him thank
you